in this video we will study about the
DNA replication DNA replication is the
biological process of producing two
identical replicas of the DNA from one
original DNA molecule and as simple as
it may seem it is one of the most
complicated biological processes and
involves the accurate copying of almost
6.5 billion base pairs in a complete set
of DNA during each cell division DNA
replication takes place inside the
nucleus of the cell there are two
identical and new copies of the DNA are
synthesized from the original DNA the
newly formed set of DNA will then be
transferred to the future' nucleus that
is produced during the process of cell
division at the end of cell division we
have two completely new cells each
having its own set of DNA and the
previous videos in this section we
discussed in detail about the structure
and function of the DNA about nucleic
acids and we also talked about the
concepts of complementary base pairing
and directionality these concepts are
essential for understanding the process
of DNA replication so make sure to watch
both these videos for a better
understanding of this section now let's
talk about the overview of the process
of DNA replication what you see here is
the simple double helix model of the DNA
in this model you can note that it
consists of these two blue lines which
basically represent the sugar phosphate
backbones of the DNA and at the center
we have these orange lines which
represent the nitrogenous base pairs of
the DNA if we untwist this double helix
model we will get something which is
known as the stepladder model of the DNA
which is a simple depiction of the
structure of the DNA
in this example you can see that the DNA
consists of these two identical strands
which almost run parallel to each other
now in the process of DNA replication
what happens is that these two strands
separate the original DNA which
separates to form these two strands is
called the parent DNA and then these two
strands which are separated from each
other act as templates upon which new
strands are copied and formed now this
process is made possible by the concept
of complementary base pairing basically
we discussed the process of
complementary base pairing in detail in
the previous videos and in a nutshell
you can note that the DNA consists of
four nucleobases which are the adenine
cytosine guanine and thymine in the
structure of the DNA the base adenine
always pairs with the base thymine and
the base guanine always pairs with the
base cytosine this is called the
chargaff's rule of DNA complementary
base pairing this is done so to maintain
a proper distance between the two
strands and also maintains a proper
stable structure of the DNA helix when
the parent DNA split each strand acts as
a template for the formation of new
strand this leads to formation of two
completely new sets of DNA which are
called
as the daughter DNA now if you take a
closer look at this step ladder model of
the DNA you can note that it consists of
these two strands which are joined
together in the center by hydrogen bonds
now these two strands run in completely
opposite direction to each other which
means they are anti parallel and they
also have a direction now in DNA we
don't have the north south east or west
directions but on DNA we have two ends a
five prime end and a three prime end of
this strand and since the strand above
is running in completely opposite
direction it will have its 3 prime end
on this side and its 5 prime end on this
side so due to this the strand below is
said to be running from the 5 prime to 3
prime direction and the Strand above is
said to be running from the 3 prime to 5
prime direction now to understand the
concept of direction in DNA in a better
way let's take a brief and close look at
the structure of the DNA now in this
example you can see the different
nucleotides and how they are joined
together in
and DNA
if we take one nucleotide out from this
strand you can see the simple depiction
of the chemical structure of a
nucleotide we will not go into the
details as we have discussed the
structure in detail in previous videos
but you can note that we have three
important groups in a nucleotide which
are the phosphate the sugar and the
nitrogenous base now if we isolate the
deoxyribose sugar from this nucleotide
we can see that the carbon atoms in the
deoxyribose sugar are numbered from 1 to
5 in a clockwise manner with a fifth
carbon outside the ring now you can
compare this illustration with a
chemical structure of deoxyribose for a
better clarification and it is the fifth
carbon to which the phosphate group is
always attached now if you take a look
at the structuralist raishin of a single
strand of DNA again you can note how the
deoxyribose sugars are arranged in this
single strand and you can also see how
all the deoxyribose sugars are aligned
in this direction due to this
orientation the fifth carbon is always
located on this side to which the
phosphate groups are attached and the
third carbon are always located on the
this side to which the hydroxyl group is
attached this defines the five prime end
and the three prime end of this strand
of the DNA now if you take a look at the
second strand of the DNA you can note
the key difference that is that it runs
in completely opposite direction which
you can clearly tell by looking at the
orientation of the sugar molecules in
this strand these sugar molecules are
aligned in this direction which is
completely opposite to the strand below
and this defines the three prime end and
the five prime end of this strand now
the question arises why is the
conservative direction important in DNA
replication well this is because the
main enzyme of the DNA replication which
is DNA polymerase it can only add new
nucleotides as a three prime end of the
DNA this means that the process of DNA
replication can only progress from the
five prime end to the three prime end of
the DNA this is because the new
nucleotides can only be added at the
three prime end well we will get into
the details of the concept of direction
in DNA replication later in this video
now let's talk about the various enzymes
that make this complex process of DNA
replication possible in this table we
will study about the name the symbol and
the function of the enzyme involved in
the process of DNA replication the first
enzyme that we will discuss is the
enzyme helicase which will be denoted by
this symbol the main job of the enzyme
helicase is that it unzips the double
helix structure of the DNA the enzyme
helicase performs this function by
breaking the hydrogen bonds between the
base pairs this separates these two
strands creating the replication fork
upon which various other enzymes will
add in the process of DNA replication so
the next enzyme we will discuss is the
enzyme DNA polymerase which will be
denoted by this symbol the DNA
polymerase performs the vital function
of formation of a new strand of DNA
known as the daughter strand now in this
example you can see the replication fork
created by the enzyme helicase and here
is the five prime end on the left and
the 3 prime end on the right of the
upper part of the DNA the DNA polymerase
performs a function of formation of a
new strand by arranging new nucleotides
in the form of a DNA strand by using the
parent DNA as a template
now you can also note that the DNA
polymerase cannot synthesize a brand new
strand but requires a small sequence of
RNA to do so this action is performed by
another enzyme the next enzyme which we
will discuss is the enzyme RNA primase
the RNA primase will be denoted by this
symbol like we just discussed the DNA
polymerase cannot initiate the synthesis
of a new strand of DNA from scratch
so the enzyme Primus synthesizes a short
segment of RNA known as the primer which
acts as a guide for the DNA polymerase
to synthesize the strand further now
this short segment of primer is later
removed and replaced by a new segment of
DNA the next enzyme we will talk about
is the DNA ligase which will be
represented by this symbol in the
process the DNA ligase performs a vital
function of joining together of the
Okazaki fragments on the lagging strand
now this may seem complex right now but
we will get to this in detail later in
this video
and the final enzyme we will talk about
is the enzyme topoisomerase which will
be denoted by this symbol the DNA is a
double helical structure which consists
of two strands of DNA which are twisted
around each other when the enzyme
helicase opens up the DNA there is
generation of stress in DNA strands
which can lead to supercoiling of DNA
now this process is solved by
topoisomerase which cut and resealed the
fragments of DNA to relieve the stress
that is produced by unzipping of the DNA
so this was part one of this video in
which we discussed the overview the
concepts of directionality and the
various replication enzymes involved in
the process of DNA replication in part 2
of this video we will study about the
actual replication process thank you so
much guys for watching this video make
sure to subscribe us on youtube for all
the latest videos and also make sure to
like our page on facebook for all the
latest updates and flashcards you can
also follow us on instagram for all the
latest flashcards